I think it's important for us today to
have a deep understanding of the
complexity of human affairs and the ways
in which for example business and law
and politics and culture all intersect
an evangelist lifetime for example we
see that you know the business world was
very closely connected to changes in
political values and changes in cultural
values in America that Vanderbilt early
life wasn't simply about a poor farm boy
who was lifting himself up by his
bootstraps it's about the the end of an
older hierarchical patrician culture in
America that we had during the colonial
era and that the revolution had helped
to undermine and that the rise of a new
competitive individualistic commercial
marketplace help help really wipe out
and that it was also closely tied to the
new jacksonian politics you know this
very kind of individualistic anti
hierarchical attitude toward society
toward business heard politics it was
all intersected and the ways in which
you know early cultural and and social
and political attitudes continue on and
they often the thread continues even
though kind of twists around and shows
up in odd places for example today's in
today's world we have the Tea Party
movement and people are often flummox
that there's this kind of populists
outraged at the government when in fact
the great mass of people actually
benefit from a lot of so-called big
government programs like Medicare and
Social Security but in fact a kind of
fear of a large central government
started off in life in American history
is a very radical idea because
government originally would had
intervened in the economy it tended to
grant favors to wealthy and patrician
men and so the radical said no stop
doing this keep the government out of
the economy because we
want every individual to rise by his or
her own merits and once you had big
business you had the rise of big
business and that changed the playing
field and the political discussion
started to change regulation became the
radical view and yet there was in
American culture still this idea this
kind of gut instinct that originated in
a very different world very different
America but it doesn't mean that the
idea does that the kind of attitude
toward government dies it kind of lives
on and twist around and it takes a
different shape and so when I look at
today's political landscape for example
I'm never dismissive of people's
attitudes whether I agree with them or
not I can see the fact that there are
deep roots to them even when I disagree
with them in in many cases and all over
the political spectrum their ideas I
agree with and disagree with but I can
see how they they have a historical life
of their own in a sense but you know
more specifically i would i would like
you know people who are involved in both
in business also i think it's important
for them to think about some of the
issues that i mentioned about the ceo's
responsibility to shareholders to
regulators and two people in our
policymakers in Congress for example to
understand the complexity of the
relationship between large enterprise
and the public sector and that
regulation is something that is both
necessary but also has to be handled
with a certain amount of circumspection
the fact that we get things wrong we
don't have a clear picture of our world
until much later and even then people
argue about it which doesn't mean that
regulation is not necessary it often is
it's just that we have to realize that
we may get it wrong we have to be
willing to adapt I think that that
history doesn't so much teach you
specific lessons as much as it gives you
an appreciation for the complexity
things for the for how difficult it is
to get it right even though we sometimes
have to act before we know exactly what
the right answer is